we're here with the official Green
Lantern character breakdown from
injustice - now this one's taken from
nether realms livestream but the game
launches just two weeks from now on May
16th so be sure to LIKE and subscribe to
keep up with all of our injustice -
coverage hey we're back
alright so Green Lantern retains pretty
much all the normal attacks of the
combos remember like this is back every
Green Lantern player just greet the
cyber leaf that was big back 1/3 is back
with everybody yeah that's and that's
the Green Lantern a breakdown yeah
all the good combos what's different is
a special move his special moves are
almost entirely lanterns - back right
and you can still meter burn it to be a
main combo starter you have to have at
and then every other special move is a
brand new attack cool so let's go over
let's do it well first is throw it's a
good one
alright so let's start with bold over
which is a spiked bowling ball it's a
low very fast moving projectile with
great recovery and you can just kind of
can you meter burn it you can't tell me
more and they'll actually be bold oh wow
look at that
ah then instead of the O's rocket he has
this battery blast super fast moving
high damaging projectile can you do it
in the air you can't leave this and you
lean if you meter burn it it is actually
becomes a high damaging super fast beam
that it's full screen instantly and you
can do the meter burn in the air as well
that's awesome
then he gets this explosion exploding
lantern out of a battery bomb battery
bomb where and you can control this
there's a closed a medium and a far and
this is a relatively safe very quick
bomb that's going to leave the opponent
guessing so you know can you meet a
Brandt you can't you can and if you do
you miss guys with everything you can
get a lantern smite and good combo wow
so this is a great screen control move
that's totally going to regulate space
you can use the fireballs on an AI
character or anything and then you put
up the battery place that was Atrocitus
talking to Dexter yeah I know what that
was okay and then finally he has
willpower wall and this will actually
nullify projectiles and it is an
excellent wake up attack and you can
meter burn it and pushes the wall over
which is an also good wakeup - it is
truly a great wake up attack it's very
very hard to jump over it's advantageous
on block it's an excellent get off me
tool and it knocks far away so if you
pull it knocks you down you know flash
starts as mixed up you get off me and
then you go back to your projectiles so
you skate by the change below there his
gameplay has changed a lot up close he
still is a great neutral game character
he still controls like this mid-range
but now from a distance he's even better
at the keep away game that he was in the
original awesome as character power is
returning its the ring power and this
adds a damage buff to all of his attacks
and it actually enhances some of the
special moves
for example his normal fireball you can
see in speed when he has the character
character power active you can make it
go faster or slower look at that slow
guy yeah and then you can do it any
speed you want so you can do fast or
slow and that works in the air as well
it also makes fold-over accomplish them
Oh does outdone it does you're the
professional there oh you went for the
half second fate I take so much help
look at that willpower I just show Isaac
it did not to screw up on stream too
many times
yes and it'll add a damage buff to all
these moves you can see it'll change the
reactions of East my way up and now it's
very easy to complement Green Lanterns I
fart well it's got so many tools yeah
he's a great all-around character who's
really really good to keep the opponent
out and he's pretty good when he gets in
where's the weak would you say I would
say um he doesn't have the best
overheads his four threes is decent but
it's a lot slower than it was in the
original I think it's now something that
people are going to be able to react to
and I would say if the opponent has even
better projectiles with him like you
care to like Deadshot or dr. fate or
dark side then he might be in some
trouble trying to get in but one thing
is in the original his mobility was very
very weak it's it's not pretty decent
his back - doesn't cover a lot of space
when his foreign - it's great for dashes
excellent so if he's having trouble you
know closing the gap because they have
even better zoning you can now actually
get in a lot easier he couldn't
awesome so you wanna look at some
loadouts I did was super oh I forgotten
right it's a good one let's do
BAM I love the giant head bobbing
nothing is so good hmm all right see
what we got next
all right load up comm load out I'm
getting a lot of people asking why we're
not showing a lot of premiere skins and
that is because a lot of them we'd like
you to discover for yourself yeah we
should keep some stuff so yeah we've
shown a lot of things and there's some
things we want you guys to be surprised
by and we still have more things to show
yeah we do in this I'll load out Green
Lantern has been corrupted by rage he
has given to his interfere and he's
become a Red Lantern oh is that why he's
red that's why he's rest also duck star
bit him in the finger and he got really
mad about so now he's a Red Lantern
okay Steve and I gave him and you can
actually see it changes all of his
effects to be red and it even changes
his UI his character power Oh so the
first ability I gave him replaces his
character power and instead he gets this
damaged on the fire once this is active
and it has on a cool-down he'll take
significantly less damage it's like 50%
it's very very significant so if you're
the type of player and you're like I
don't want to keep you cool out that's
why I want to go Yolo I'm the Yolo man
that sounds so like me exactly so if
you're Derek and all you do is wake up
attacks and jump ins you can turn this
on and you can go Yolo and if you get
punished for it you're barely gonna take
any date I'm
okay yeah cool so another thing is
you'll notice a lot of the good stuff
requires meter mm-hmm
so he has quick charge where the lantern
will actually appear it'll start
charging and you can see building super
meter oh and you can stop this at any
time so if you're playing a match and
you're keeping the opponent out and the
opponent's like well you know what I
have a projectile reflex or something
I'm not going to come in well then
you're building meter what now
yeah come get me come get him so that I
mean that's another maybe another
weakness a lantern is a lot of stuff
does require me it does yeah he took got
in full right he either needs his
character power or meter so this is
another example how they complement each
other since he won't have the enhanced
lanterns might if he uses this he can
then use meter for popups
can you by using picture shoe is super
in the red and you need more meter Steve
OH
Oh Oh
that's awesome nice all right cool
one more one more so another thing is
maybe you were a big fan of how he
played in part one maybe you like two
setups maybe you like the downwards
fireball maybe you like the machine gun
which kept people out we haven't just
got rid of those moves they're still
available as ability so you can see the
original oh is rocket is bad oh and it
has the same properties it's extremely
quick and you can meet a bourbon and
then go into a combo and I also gave him
the old vinegar nice so remember this
strategy yeah it's bad it's bad if you
really want to if you really want to
stay away and make sure you never get it
again you got many guns back that's all
so if you want to play like he did more
in the original injustice you can set
that up and of course you can mix and
match you could have lanterns barrier is
mixed with arrow is rocket or you could
have regular air battery blasts mixed
with straight rockets there's many many
possibilities and the turbines in there
there's several other moves are don't
give it all away always all right well I
think that would be it for the
characters were to show today we do have
this dream was gone about an hour and a
half so nice work on that they take that
controller we do we have to end the way
we always add and I know the streams a
little long and we hope that doesn't
bother anybody we want to get as much in
I can't imagine the fans